Hello, everyone. It is June 16,
2022, and it's meeting seven of the
active textbook textbook group Cohort
one. We're in our second discussion of
chapter three today.
We'll be looking at the questions that
haven't been addressed, so the ones
without thumbs. And also,
it's not too late to add more questions
or to upvote questions. And then
additionally, since the Math Learning
Group has been quite active in
providing synchronous affordances for
conversation around some of the
background on the Math as well as some
aspects of the equations that we'll go
through today and also even to
applications of the math and developing
notebooks and such.
We'll take a look at the math in
our move through chapter three.
Before we go to the questions, does
anyone have anything that they just want
to remark on chapter three,
Ali and then anyone else?
Yeah. Well, last week I talked about how
I changed my mind about these bottom up
and top down characterizations of low
road and high road, respectively, after
reading chapter three, but it turns out
that they are, in fact, bottom up and
top down approaches after all. You see,
I came across this, in my opinion,
undeservedly lesser known piece of
beautiful, beautiful writing by Karl
Frisden which explicitly argues for such
characterizations and the philosophical
importance of this distinction. It's
called beyond the Desert Landscape, and
it's inconspicuously hidden in this
book, Andy Clark and his critics.
So I'd like to quote a couple
of sentences from this writing.
Well, he writes quote the high road
stands in for a top down approach that
starts by asking fundamental questions
about the necessary properties things
must possess if they exist. Using
mathematical variational principles,
one can then show that existence is an
embodied exchange of a creature with its
environment that necessarily entails
predictive processing as one aspect of a
self evidencing mechanics. The low road
is the purpose. The agenda established
is to pursue the agenda established by
Kant and Hellholtz and generalize in a
bottom up way, the capacity for
inference and prediction to see how far
it takes us in understanding embodied
exchange with the environment. So if
anyone likes to gain a deeper
understanding about these conceptual
characterizations, I highly, highly
recommend this chapter of this book.
And quite unusually for Frison writing,
it also lacks any mathematical
formalism. It doesn't include a single
mathematical equation there.
Thank you. Yeah. In a recent
stream, we also talked about the desert
landscape. And Clark's concern was that
we might do away with what populates are
implicitly assumed to be rich ecosystems
of psychology, philosophy and so on,
with important ecosystem players like
goals. And so the fear
or concern was that we might be in a
quineyan desert landscape. If we replace
some of these, again, implicitly or
explicitly stated, to be rich constructs
like goals, and we're like, well, it's
just distribution matching, then we've
made some sort of like a desert
monoculture. And that would be depoprant
of what does Clark say to
his desert living critics?
All right, if anyone else has a
thought, they can raise their hand.
Otherwise we can look at the questions.
Okay, so this first question if
one defines preferred states as expected
states, one can say living organisms
must minimize the surprise of their
sensory observations. I'm not clear on
the ontology here. Is it that preference
is the same as expectation or that
formally we can use them in the same
equation? Is that an ontological claim?
And is the free Energy and physics an
analogy or an ontological assertion
about how things really are?
So one starting place was
I found the slide and so wanted to
highlight it. This was in Free Energy,
a user's guide which was live. Stream
number 37.
The slides will be probably a little
bigger.
It's worth restating just how unusual it
is to interpret P as a measure of both
probabilities and preferences. They both
start with P, though there's nothing
wrong with treating a distribution as a
measure of preferences because
distributions can have different
interpretations. But what's unorthodox
and in need of justification is giving
the same mathematical term two different
interpretations within the same
equation.
They then add some more details that
unpack a little bit about how it
is the case that the same term,
P can be utilized as
both a probability and a preference.
And then they even extended it into a
third P, the, the PH fitness,
where by allowing your probabilities
and your preferences to converge to
reduce the divergence between those two
distributions, then fitness
is achieved.
And so they provided a
restatement of the way that that is
implemented and then highlighted
in additional grounding or interpretive
line.
So that's at
least one part of that question.
And also to look towards the equations.
It's something that we'll be able to
have very clear answers for and thanks
to the work of Ali and Blue and others
who have been annotating equations.
So for example, in equation 3.1,
or we can look at like box one,
equation one, which is like a Markov
blanket definition.
In the description field we
have a natural language description
and then the terms that are used in
the description are those that are
referenced using variables. So that will
help us translate across natural
language of different human languages,
the discrete and continuous time
formalisms which we're going to explore
in this textbook, also identical
or isomorphic or related formalisms in
other papers which sometimes are using
the same notation letters, but not
always. But we could have another column
for first in 2019 and here's first in
2013 and then there's a conversation to
be had about where they align or don't.
And that's the kind of annotation work
that somebody can engage in from the
publications and that also helps us
connect it to the programmatic
implementations like in Active Block,
for instance, or in other scripts.
So that even that we can promote norms
and practices around variable naming in
math and in programming, but also where
there is divergences or differences
which are important for innovating and
evolving the norms. We can also map them
pretty coherently so all the equations
for three can be read
naturally. So we discussed this a lot in
the math group and again, a lot of
people contributed to this with one of
the goals or functions being that
whenever we are going to bring up an
equation, like if there's a question
about equation 3.1.
We can just briefly read
the current state of the description.
Because whether you're super familiar
with the letters and variables and how
they're concatenated, or whether it's
just like a first pass on your seeing
this equation. Everybody will
benefit when we align our regime of
attention to actually what it says,
and then that will help us do many,
many other things.
But to return back to this question,
does anyone want to raise their hand and
give a thought on the relationship
between preference and expectation?
Ontological claims about preference
and its relationship with expectation
and more generally,
is the free energy something that
is an analogy or mathematical
isomorphism or an equation that rhymes
or is it also an assertion?
It it's an equation that rhymes.
What makes you say that? No, just
because it's
cute, that's all.
I just joined the conversation. But
preference and expectation, I wouldn't
think they were at all referring
to the same thing.
Expectation is a mathematical operator.
Preference is a
statement. Yes.
Expectation is used in multiple ways.
It can refer to predictions about
the mean or the mode or other attributes
of a future time point like I'm
expecting, what are you expecting to
happen on next Monday? Also,
expectation can refer and that's how
it's used with the fancy e to refer to
the expected value of a distribution
which for a gaussian is the mode
in the center of a symmetric peak.
And that doesn't need to be about a
future time point, that can just be the
expectation of the height of the
classroom. Right now it's not saying
that's what we're expecting it to be in
a year as it might be used
conversationally but it's referring to
just like the average of a distribution.
Right? Mathematically it's an operator
and verbally it. Can be.
A prediction or a desire or something.
Yes. And then again in 37 and
elsewhere it'll
be worth returning to this again and
again because it's one of the essential
architectural decisions in active
inference that enable it's
part of the necessity and sufficiency
complex. I don't know whether this is
the whole meat of it, but it's part of
what allows the dispensal of an explicit
reward term, like a homeostatic
reinforcement. Reward driven learner
would be like, I'm more rewarded by
being in my homeostatic range. And then
there needs to be this architecture
around. Well, how are we going to pursue
reward? Alternatively,
an organism trying to maintain
homeostasis realism or us modeling an
organism that is maintaining homeostasis
instrumentalism. We can just say it
expects to be in the range.
That conversationally we're going to
describe as a preference. How do we
know? We put the animal in the room and
it's spending a lot of its time on this
warmer side. It prefers to be
there. We also expect it to be there.
We're less surprised when we see it
there. So then it's
possible to as they right here interpret
that p location distribution in the
room for the animal that we're observing
or the temperature distribution for the
body in the homeostatic context as being
a probability density over.
Temperatures over locations as well as
reflecting the preferences, not the
qualia or the phenomenology or anything
like too far out about what it means to
prefer where preferences arise from,
whether they're fixed or learned in the
model. All these many, many trails that
can come out of that. But just at this
essential layer, we don't need to
interpolate a reward term between what
is expected and what is preferred.
Any other comments from someone? Yes,
Eric, and then anyone else?
Yeah, just to remark on that,
it seems you're still not removing the
free variable of what the preference of
the agent organism is. You're just
holding it. You're putting it in a
different place so that you can use it
in this unified equation. But you
still have this it's a free variable.
What do you want to do? Okay, I'm going
to call that an expectation. And that's
what I'm going to try to drive for when
I optimize my variational, free energy.
But in that sense, it's kind of a
convenience or it's a trick. It's a
little bit of an unnatural act. I don't
know the way I think of it, for a
purpose.
But you haven't solved any other
problem. The deeper problem of what
should the organism attempt to achieve
the goals.
Yes. Thanks, Ali.
Well, I think it also might be quite
helpful to refer back to chapter two on
page 36, I think. Yeah, page 36 here
they have actually distinguished between
the term prediction and exactly. Yes.
Here the term prediction and expectation
quite explicitly in terms of equation
2.6.
Okay. So let's look at equation 2.6.
Okay. A few of them,
we don't have the third line fully
described, but just here's the third
line. What does this speak to with
respect to preferences and expectations?
Here the preference actually is in the
second term, the Kullback Leibler
divergence. Here. Yeah.
It's actually inherent in the second
term. And the expectation, expected
ambiguity, as it speaks for itself
is the first term. So we have here the
risk is defined as the divergence
between the preference and the states.
So I think that we can see the
preference in this equation as well.
One note here is like that this G is
equal to the first, the second,
and this line.
But one way that we can understand the
relationship of the second and the third
line is like they're very similar. The
first term is identical here.
The only difference is that instead of a
Y, we see an X.
And so this is like X being the hidden
state and Y being the observation.
In the case where it's a fully
observable Markov process,
then the outcomes and the hidden states
are going to be like equal uncertainty
about them. Because in that case
it's functionally that the hidden states
are observables. However, if there's any
amount of ambiguity like the a matrix
between the hidden state and the
observable, then there's always going to
be more uncertainty about the hidden
state relative to the observable.
And then importantly, on both sides
there's a conditioning vertical line on
policy selection. And so that
is what prevents us from getting into
the like, well, what if it's 95% correct
or 96 or 97% correct or any of these
sort of like model diminishing returns
debates. It's a functional that's
calculated for each policy that have
been possible of composing
given the affordances. A policy is just
a sequence of actions. So if there's
four movement affordances, there's four
policies of time depth one, there's 16
policies of time depth two, and so on
and for whatever in this discrete,
formalism, finite set of policies,
there are they're evaluated here and
then there's a policy selection that
could choose the lowest expected free
energy, or it could proportionally
choose from them with different kinds of
weighting and so on. But this is
comparing the relative expected
ambiguity and risk conditioned upon
different specific policies. And there's
a process by which those specific
policies can be enumerated and then this
is a process by which they're going to
be evaluated and then there's a policy
selection by which they're selected. So
organisms that fail to do this
adequately enough will be dissipated.
Or systems, whether it's just a
molecular system or some other kind of
statistical system that fail to do this
well enough to remain being that kind of
thing, are not amenable to repeated
measurements. They are not that thing.
But things that remain being that thing
for the time horizon of observations
will be selecting policies that are
consistent with this.
Can I ask a question about this? Yeah,
about this equation here, say like
the second line.
So first of all, see the preferences is
not really spelled out very much in this
chapter and I don't know where it will
be, but I would
have expected something more like
preferences given observations like
the observations, what's happened in the
world that we can measure that's
observation. Why?
And then how does that fit with my
preferences? So what I want to optimize
is my preference, the achievement of my
preferences as delivered by the
observations. Now, I understand that
in that second equation you're going to
do a divergence between observations,
the Y tilde. So you can't flip around p
of C given y tilde there. So can
somebody explain to me how this all fits
together then? How do you achieve
preferences under that equation?
I'll give one thought and I
absolutely agree to the first point,
which is like c is just like I don't
even know if it's described in this
chapter. 34,
I think. 34,
let me check it again.
I mean there is he said parameter.
Includes preferences but it includes
parameter. Yeah. And also if
you go to section 7.4 I think
yes, in that section
it is untangled why these two parameters
are related and how these two parameters
are related to each other.
That's like multiple scales of where the
information is not provided before when
it needs to be provided. Which is like
this I have made as just a helpful
diagram of the partially observable
Markov decision process which is C is
the preferences and it influences how G
evaluates policies which are generated
from affordances over a given time
horizon. Policies intervene upon how
hidden states change in the world and
there's more in different readings. But
to return to Eric's question and then
again, anyone with the raised hand so
the question was whether we're comparing
outcomes or states, how does
this second term help us realize our
preference? Well,
when is the KL? We're trying to minimize
g of pi better policies have a lower
score. It's like golf, I guess, or you
could add negatives and make it higher.
And also just it's an interesting note
like climbing Mount Improbable,
biologists often think about the fitness
peak and climbing to fitness peaks,
whereas for a physicist it's often
framed. And also like computer science
gradient descending and local minima,
global minima, but they're just actually
like the same landscape with some
negative signs. So the KL divergence and
here we're trying to minimize if it's
zero that would mean like we are
perfectly realizing our preference.
So let's just say that there's two
policies that we're comparing between
and one of them is going to perfectly
realize our preferences, the other one
isn't. So we have like pi one and pi two
and we're going to be calculating the KL
divergence of the outcomes that we're
expecting under the variational
distribution Q under policy one and
under policy two. So if policy
one is going to perfectly realize if
the outcomes of policy one are expected
to perfectly realize our preferences,
this term will be zero.
Whereas if policy two is going to be
expected to result in an outcome
distribution that's not aligned with our
preferences, it doesn't get penalized
here. This is just evaluated as
a value. Nor does it get penalized here
because in this case of fixed
preferences that's also not changing as
we iterate through policies. However,
there would be a divergence that would
be nonzero. Like all divergences are
between the inferior policy and the
superior policy. So by iterating over
the finite set of policies that we have
taking this term and just leaving it to
the side. For now, only the KL
divergence. This will lead us to select
policies that can be expected to bring
alignment between the observations
conditioned on policy and our
preferences. Preferred outcome
distribution. Thank you, that's very
helpful. So just to kind of say that
slightly differently is given your
preferences, that's going to imply some
outcomes. And what you're trying to do
with that KL divergence is you're trying
to get the policy that will achieve
those outcomes.
So if we expect and prefer
to be within the homeostatic thermal
range and then the two policies in the
snowstorm are add the jacket or remove
the jacket, which one of those
are expected to have the minimum
divergence between us being in the
homeostatic range and then the policy
conditioned expected outcomes?
I'm going to have less divergence. It
doesn't even mean you're going to live.
It just means I'm going to have less
divergence by having the jacket on in
the snowstorm than by taking it off,
which is going to move the expected
outcome distribution further from the
preference distribution, which here is
fixed, but doesn't have to be fixed.
Okay,
so we have several is
anyone here the person who has written
any of these questions? And then we can
just go to that one.
Lyle?
Yes. There we go. I think I'm on here.
Okay, so yeah, I wrote the one that
is referring to the living organisms and
the question about to what extent are
these techniques valuable in what
I would call social systems of wide
ranging sorts. And I know
that this book at the outset limits
itself to biological systems, at least
that's my recollection from the
introduction, but it just seems obvious
to me that this would have much broader
applicability. I'm curious what
the state of that is.
Well,
do I hesitate to put anyone on the spot?
John, would you give a first response
there while I add some resources?
Yeah, my first thought on that is
obviously our civilization is struggling
and civilizations have failed in the
past who collapsed. So it's not
necessarily the case that every social
structure or societal structure is
actually performing functional active
inference. But if we were a highly
functional organism, if societies were a
highly functional organism, we would be
doing something like active inference
and learning from our mistakes and
making sure that we put ourselves in an
environment that is sustainable and all
that kind of stuff. So my first thought
is, I think that all of this is
applicable to societal systems, but it
doesn't necessarily mean that any
existing societal systems actually
perform functional active inference.
Yeah, thanks. It's almost like saying,
hey, we're studying the penguins and
their thermostats and homeostats. This
model could be parameterized to fit a
thriving or a failing society along
various different dimensions. And so in
the sense that this is like a linear
aggression that can capture failing as
well as succeeding societies. Yes, the
Nested Markov blanket formalism has
qualitatively, but increasingly
quantitatively been applied. And there's
multiple startups and applications that
are explicitly pursuing this angle.
It's been brought up for several years
now and in 2020 several
of us wrote about it being applied to
remote teams and organizations and
communities. I can add these links to
decentralized science as a system and
ecosystem. So yes, people have
started to sketch that continent out and
there's a lot more to understand.
What do you think, Lyle? Yeah,
I think that makes a ton of sense. I
think obviously, I guess the way I was
thinking about the question is not so
much whether to what extent social
systems do this because social systems
so you could take two points of view.
One is you could say social systems are
behaving cognitively in the ways that
we're discussing. In other words,
there are preferred states that are
driving behavior. Now, we could say
those preferred states are the wrong
states for whatever reasons.
So there's a question between what we
actually in any particular social system
was actually happening, which I would
argue could be described through this
technique, or what they should be doing,
which we could also describe through
this technique. Right? So I think
it's important to have that distinction.
And there's a really long history of
using dynamic systems models to explore
those questions, especially in the
business context. That's mostly how I
made my living through the decades.
So that sort
of as is to be or would
prefer to be sort of questioned. It just
seems like this technique would
potentially be a significant advance
over the tools in that space that
currently exists, which are primarily
things like system dynamics and agent
based modeling, stuff like that. But
this would seem to have the potential to
look at things as they are, why is it
broken and what we might do. Yes,
so I have added several other
references. It's important. And the
book, again, is like, if it's describing
the linear model, then there's the
applications of the linear model and as
people and as John brought up, like many
times in this series of live streams
that we did, together with four with
just the two of us, with John leading
through basically the entire thread of
this discussion of three papers and then
two more group discussions. There's been
recent work on scripts by Mahault and
colleagues with a strong and a weak
script formalization, like a strong
script being when the norms are
practiced, like in a ritualistic way,
like reading from a script, versus the
looser script concept, which could
include just norms and social practice.
And then more recently they're modeling
work using Pi MDP to talk about
epistemic communities. And then some of
the very earliest live streams that we
did were on narrative, human
communication, cultural affordances.
So these are absolutely topics that have
been addressed, although many of the
earlier works are like here's
people in the world, we're going to use
active inference to model it. But then
there's so much more beyond that.
It's almost like a 1950s cybernetics
book. Well, we can just imagine that the
person is going to be involved in this
feedback loop, but then that's not the
end of the discussion on that. Ali and
then, John.
I just wanted to mention that, well,
FEP can potentially be applied to
any dynamical system with Ergodicity,
because you see,
any system with Ergotic behavior
have some points of attraction, some
attractors that all
the other states are converging to. So
it's pretty general. And well,
almost all dynamical systems we know of
on different timescales can be
potentially modeled with FEP
and as its corollary with active
inference. Thank you. That's a key
point, right? Because that's what we
look at. Your gotta this is the tough
word for me. And and you can actually
look at that even in the context of
businesses business strategy and so
forth, with some understanding of the
absorbing barriers. Right. When does a
business dissipate when it's not close
enough to its preferred state, like
adequate cash flow?
I think that just seems like a really
interesting progression from where the
state of the art of dynamic, nonlinear
dynamic systems is the way we model
businesses now. Well, that's the way
some of us do it. A lot of people use a
spreadsheet, but this would
just seem like a potentially tremendous
advancement. Yeah. And then just a few
notes then, John, this Stephen Fox who's
also joined and talked about industrial
engineering, he's recently had this
paper come out just a couple of days
ago. And ironically, a spreadsheet is
provided in this paper, but this is also
in practice in several places in the
world in startup ecosystems,
and it's very academic influenced. And
then one other more conceptual note,
Cadcad, which is the complex systems
modeling software, and I know some of
you are involved in Cadcad learning as
well. They describe it as a language for
encoding generalized dynamical systems.
And that is what it is. Active Block,
for instance, is our project where
Yaakob has done much of the initial work
that is implementing active inference in
Cadcad. And we have a whole litany of
questions about the relationships
between Bayes graphs, generalized
dynamical systems variational inference,
cadcad, which takes more of like a
sampling based approach versus the
variational approaches that we're
discussing here in Active. And it's
going to be very interesting as this
systems engineering, complex systems
simulation, as well as tokenomic and
other things becomes integrated with
this analytical framework, especially if
we can demonstrate a true concordance
between active inference and GDS. John
Lyle, I just wanted to say your comments
are really spot on. Earlier comments,
I think, if I can paraphrase, you had
essentially said maybe even a
dysfunctional society is performing
active inference. And then that would
lead us to really to the key components
then of that society or that social
system is what is its set of preferred
states and where is it placing its
attention? So if,
say, an elite group of very wealthy
people or powerful people are running
the world and they're running it for
their preferences, which is to maintain
their wealth and to ensure that
they stay on top, well, then the world,
they could be performing functional,
active inference, and the world could
suffer the problems that that kind of
system would offer. On the other hand,
in a highly democratic system, if people
understand that they want clean air and
clean water and peace and all that kind
of stuff and then that's their set of
preferred states and their attention is
on that and they're performing active
inference.
Thank you, John Lyle. And then Mike.
So John, I'm completely on board with
that. I would just amplify a little bit
on that. I would say to a certain extent
preferences and societal
decisions are emergent.
So you aren't going to find too many
people in the world who are going to say
they want to be starving or have war or
whatever, right, and yet we do. So the
interesting thing is to me is
how does the individual,
I mean this is the whole build up,
right? How does the individual behavior
somehow. Create.
An emergent system that has many bad
outcomes even though potentially none of
those are bad actors. Some of them are
bad actors. But let's just take the
simple case. There are no bad actors yet
we get bad outcome. Why is that? And we
can observe that in existing systems
and then we can ask the question, well
why is that? And then maybe if we
understand why that is, maybe we can do
something to improve. Yes,
great point. And then just a short note,
there was in our remote teams we've
framed communication and information
architectures as organizational
affordances so that could assist with
decision making, find alignment where
people do have similar preferences,
like a zone of proximate agreement. In a
negotiation context it might be broader,
but no matter how broad it is, if you
can't forage the path to it, it's going
to be a failing system. Mike yeah,
I just want to add, I think scaling or
the scale factor is hugely important
here. So if we're talking about
interactions amongst a handful of
individuals, we're going to see
different behaviors and outcomes than we
might see on a global scale of cultural
interaction. Okay, and then the
last comment on that john, go for it.
If your hand is still up I don't hear
you actually. Okay. Your microphone may
have changed or can other people hear?
John no. Okay.
Eric, go for it. Yeah.
How does this all apply to a highly
distributed system? I don't see that.
Yes, like a society is.
Good question. The multi agent case is
something that hasn't been studied
across the board. But. In 2021 with
colleagues. This is like one of the
early it's not the first multi agent
simulation because there were multi
agent simulations. However, it was the
first active inference model involving
stigma g, which is the feedback process
with agents modifying their environments
and so on. We can think about
even a Nested distributed cognitive
system as inheriting some sparsity from
a causal perspective. Like there's more
connections in the Bayes graph within
the Nest mate's head as we're modeling
it and then interactions induce like a
sparsity between two brains and then
they're always coupled with the
environment and so on. And that sparsity
is a statistical convenience, but also
it allows factorizability of models and
the models may be factorized in a way
where free energy calculations could be,
for example, summed within a level of
collective behavior. I don't know if
that's going that's not the solution in
and of itself to the modeling. But when
we have systems of like Nested Markov
blankets, enclosing systems and closing
systems and then also lateral
interactions and interfaces like
collective behavior, those systems are
at least amenable to this kind of
principled composition via their
sparsity, which does map onto a causal
architecture or at least a useful one of
the real world. So also remains to be
seen. But I think that's a very
important question.
Lyle yeah, Eric, I would
throw in on that question because
society of course, broadly speaking is
loosely coupled. However, of course
there are clicks and densely coupled
areas that create the well
documented complex connection graphs,
right? So that connection graph is
emergent, right? So the question is, I
think this would be actually a really
fascinating research project. Can we
show that FEP would generate connection
graphs or patterns of
societal interactions similar to what
has been observed? Right, so there's
lots and lots of research on what those
graphs look like. So is it possible for
us to or someone to use
FEP to show how those kind of connection
patterns would emerge? I think that's
a really interesting question, yes. How
we threshold and parameterize
those causal graphs, how we evaluate
counterfactuals on those graphs and
that's related to the problem of
structured learning. But Bayesian model
selection and other sort of hierarchical
Bayesian methods have the tools.
There also just quick pointer to the
project ideas table there's some very
interesting projects that people have
suggested. Jakub, no big deal,
sounds like a good one, but we can
absolutely do it. And that's one of the
advantages of being in an activity
driven, participatory research and
education space is we're hopefully going
to be able to help each other identify
those projects and where there has or
hasn't been overlap and then scaffold
those projects, support them and then
provide them like a place to communicate
about the project. Playing into the
ontology active blockprints. All these
pieces that one researcher working by
themselves would have just not
those affordances. Let's just try to
quickly look at the last several
questions.
Must all preferred states and strategies
be ultimately linked to survival in some
way? Or in the case of some organisms,
can free energy be related to something
other than survival? So just a
quick thought on that. In the context of
repeated measurements yes,
survival is the capacity for repeated
measurements. Free energy energies
for domain specific models can
be made that have nothing to do with
survival. And I don't think that there's
any contradiction there.
John,
I still don't hear you, actually.
Rohan and then anyone else who raises
their hand. Yeah,
hi. So I was actually wondering because
there's no treatment of time in any of
these methods, right?
Is there any accommodation made? So if
you're sampling something, let's say you
sample at a minute frequency, you're
getting a certain set of events,
whereas if you're sampling at a much
higher frequency, you would get a very
different, much more noisy data set.
But that might be essential to capture
certain things that might actually
enable survival. Maybe there's certain
events that act only at certain times.
So from the perspective of
repeated measurement right. So I think
free energy principle, as it relates to
survival, could it just be related to
some sort of creating an internal clock
for repeated measurement? Great
question. Yes. So far it's
been almost time independent,
as you suggest. But we're going to be
dealing with two ways to deal with time
in chapter four and beyond. And that's
like a discrete time formalization where
future and past states are explicitly
modeled, partially observable Markov
decision process. And then also a
continuous time variance where future
and past time points are not explicitly
modeled. However, a Taylor series
approximation, higher and higher
derivatives of a function are utilized
to glean an approximation to the future
behavior of a function. Those are two
different ways of dealing with time.
And then you talked about, like,
sampling rate, and I think
you'll see many connections and ways to
apply that. For example, you could
imagine, like, if the sensor is every
second, but you're able to think ten
times per second, or what about when the
sensor is every 10 seconds, but you're
only able to think over this timescale.
And it's those kinds of situations where
actually the frequencies are happening
differently that we also might be able
to address. Yes. Rohan yeah.
Also, like, if there are multiple
sensors, some of them react quickly,
some of them react slowly, or if there's
just or if we look at active inferences,
some sort of model averaging phenomena.
Right. So you have a model that runs
really fast, that reacts really quickly
and produces predictions really quickly,
and the other one acts
more slowly. Would those be valid
targets in any sense?
Yes, I think it's a very interesting
question. I'll just add it here just
because it was where we were discussing
it, like about different timescales and
the way that cognitive clock rates for
example and sensory clock rates and then
the timescale events, the statistical
regularities in the world happen.
In model stream 4.1 with DeVries
and colleagues they talked about the
message passing in a factor graph. So
anytime that there's a bayes graph
there's a way to accomplish variational
inference on that base graph using
message passing techniques. That's what
their package is about for any lab.
And then what they hinted at towards the
end is actually this reactive message
passing development which uses
reactive programming techniques. So
whereas in message passing, at least in
the 40 factor graph formalization it's
like you crank the model and a message
is passed amongst every node or there's
like a given execution order of messages
that are passed for the entire graph.
However, the reactive message passing
paradigm may allow like uncoupling
of the frequency of message passing. So
you might have one prior that gets one
message per hour and then there's
another distribution that gets one
message per minute and another one is
getting 1. Even that one could be doing
model averaging of something much
faster. So there's many ways that I
think your questions will be starting to
be explored. Rohan and then John okay
John, if. Your mic is can you hear me
now? Oh good. On the question of
survival, I think you would have to
identify to answer it, you'd have to
identify first what is the organism or
what is the agent that you're talking
about because obviously if it's an
individual person, a person might
sacrifice their life for others. So then
survival is not necessarily the main
driver but if it's a society then
any individual might not survive but
society as a whole might. I suspect in
the bigger picture that it's not
really survival of a species it's
probably the ability to the
propagation of information somehow.
That's what I would guess in the biggest
picture that's probably what everything
is doing is propagating information.
And Mike Levin has also explored how
changes in the scope of the self can
lead to an organism with reduced fitness
as a function of a cancer with increased
fitness and vision, so to speak. And so
just because there's an imperative or
normative way that we model behavior
doesn't mean that everything works or
anything like that.
Yes. Ali yes.
Adding to what John said well,
yes, again, I believe here survival
doesn't necessarily mean biological
survival and actually it
has a much broader sense and it means
the existence of things. Actually it's a
metaphysical concept here because as
I said, Karl Friston has defined
the existence or the
prerequisite of existence as having two
parameters or two features namely
being an ergotic system and having
markup blankets. So any system which has
these any system which has these two
properties can basically be considered
as an existing system or we can call it
a surviving system. Here,
just in our last minutes before we go to
tools touch on some of these points can
markup blanket be considered a
decoupling mechanism? So can anything
mathematical be considered a mechanism?
People use terms in different ways. So
that just to raise the point that a
linear aggression on height and weight
isn't a mechanism of height and weight,
it's just a descriptor. So Markov
blanket doesn't need to be any kind of
mechanism at all, it doesn't need to cut
nature at the joints or anything like
that. That being said, there are ways in
which one could think of the blanket
again variously depending on how the
real generative model and generative
process separated as part of a Markov
partition. Sometimes there's ways to
think of it as how they're coupled,
other times it is a statistical
decoupling of a type, it's a partial
information encapsulation, but it's not
a total encapsulation and that way it is
like an interface. And yes, thanks to
whomever has added this quote this is
one reason why the transcripts of all of
the live streams and discussions
augmented with the ontology will be so
helpful and searchable because we could
find sentences that have raised similar
points and address them. So, good
question and then just the last ones,
maybe we can come back to this.
And then this one is a nice
next step question thinking about
friction. What is the analogy to
friction in a cognitive system? What is
the stochastic fluctuation on our
cognitive path of least action?
What is that in the real world realism
ontological claims? And then from the
behavioral modeling perspective, where
are we using these equations and
partitioning variance into a path or
a flow of least action and a variable
that is analogous to stochastic
fluctuation or friction but doesn't take
on any of the baggage of describing some
feature or component or mechanism of the
physical system. So also a great
question though and we'll leave this one
in case people want to continue to
address it. So that brings us to the
end of chapter three live meetings.
Next week, we'll head into two weeks of
chapter four, then two weeks of chapter
five, and then we'll have two weeks to
sort of ground ourselves, think about
what we've learned, talk about project
ideas, and then we'll be heading into
the second cohort of the first half of
the book. And for those who are here who
want to continue into the back nine,
as it were, the second half of the
textbook. And also people are welcomed
and encouraged to be facilitators or
return participants in the second cohort
first part because it's many coats of
paint for everyone. And so we want to
provide that affordance to return again
and again. And again because the basics
are the classics and the essence and the
seed of innovation. All this other
important things that happen when we
return and clarify. Also we've had to
sort of do all of these entering of
figures and equations for the first time
but now that we have the architecture.
People can focus on annotating them, or
they can focus on adding new questions
or improving the questions that others
have written.
If anyone else has any comments that
they want to make while the recording is
still occurring, I'll just give a few
seconds for anyone to raise their hand
and then we'll end this session and then
take a 1 minute break. And then in this
room, we'll be continuing on with tools,
organizational unit. And if you want
to continue speaking with people here
about just any topic at all, you can
head up to a room up top and then of
course always you can join into the
discord voice channels and just be
working on things like during the math
reading group or any other area rojan
and then anyone else who raises their
hand.
Yeah, actually, sorry for this late
part. I'm just curious,
when you say the free energy principle,
it's basically figuring out some set
point of states, internal states that
the agent wants to be with, right? It's
not necessary that it
actually couples to the real world. So
why wouldn't it be that? Okay, it just
becomes a brain in the VAT type of
situation.
It just needs to find a set point that
helps it survive. So it doesn't
have to actually model the real world,
it just has to find a place and no
matter what happens, just stay there.
So it's not really dynamic. That could
be that possibility.
It is dynamic. It is explicitly modeling
time. And one can make a model just like
a linear regression could be static, or
you could use the linear regression
technique and use it in I was more
referring it. So if you look at some of
the reinforcement, deep reinforcement
learning models, right? They usually
find some trick within the game. Like if
you're looking at Atari games and you
say maximize the score, for example, so
it tries to find, okay, I can maximize
the score by doing the simplest thing
that doesn't require me to progress in
any way, but it would increase the
score. Okay? So yes,
these are important things, so write
them down so that we can have infinite
discourse on them. The brain,
the VAT does still have an interface
with the environment, whether it's
receive only and then you brought up
like it doesn't have to be like modeling
the quote real world. This is the
architecture that helps us bypass that
and say, right, the particulate states,
the particular states, which are the
blanket states and the internal states
are doing inference, acting as if
they're doing inference on external
states. So it's perfectly compatible
with scientific realism, scientific
surrealism, aesthetic surrealism.
It could be hallucinating the world,
and it's actually just doing inference
on the hallucination rather than actual
reality as such. Anil Seth and many
others who speak of that reality as a
controlled hallucination, they're 2ft in
that territory without any qualms and
feeling like it addresses questions that
have been unaddressed by other
perspectives.
Okay, so I'll just put this there.
Cool. Thank you,